yeah the white house is on one right now
the white house is gaslighting everybody
they wrote a blog post on the 19th of
july late last week to try to slide it
out there make sure uh they could point
back to it but no one really paying
attention and in it what they said was
how do you measure a recession
and
they claim how do economists determine
whether the economy is in a recession
but in the very first paragraph they
talk about how a recession is not
defined as two consecutive quarters of
negative gdp growth now i don't know
where
they could have thought that everyone in
the world thought that was the
definition
a recession
as they claim here
is two consecutive quarters of following
real gdp does not constitute a recession
that is neither the official definition
nor the way economists evaluate the
state of the business cycle [ __ ]
that is exactly what a recession is
if you go and talk to any market
participant you say hey how do you
define a recession they will all say the
same thing two consecutive quarters of
negative gdp growth
period
now what is happening is they're
pointing to nber the national bureau of
economic research
which changed the definition of a
recession last summer
and they're saying that instead official
determinations of recessions and
economist assessment of economic
activity are based on a holistic look at
the data well yeah i'd be saying that
[ __ ] too if i thought we were in a
recession
and that's why they're saying this stuff
is because they realize q1 gdp growth
was negative
q2 gdp which if they're releasing it
this week these folks already know what
the number is
you don't accidentally post this and
claim oh we just happen to be preparing
people for a potential q2 negative gdp
number
atlanta fed
they claim exactly the same thing that
q2 gdp be negative here a question was
asked to janet yellen if the technical
definition is two quarters of
contraction you're saying that's not a
recession
janet yellen like yo come on folks
that's not the technical definition
[ __ ]
there's an organization called the
national bureau of economic research man
it sounds like they handed out talking
points it sounds like all of a sudden
they all have the same talking points
that looks at a broad range of data
in deciding whether or not there's a
recession so now a recession is just
opinion now there's no definition we
just oh there's one organization that no
one knows who works there no one elected
them they just get to determine whether
it's a recession or not they're just
gonna
uh yeah we feel like today's a recession
uh tomorrow oh no now we're not in a
recession what is going on
this is math
they're trying to make it politics
it's math two consecutive quarters of
gdp negative growth means it is a
recession
now all of a sudden we have this uh
national bureau of economic research
it sounds made up like it literally just
sounds like they just put a bunch of
people in a room they put some title on
them said all right y'all just determine
when it's a recession by the way don't
forget we appointed y'all [ __ ]
so you're gonna have to do what we say
to do
this is wild go go back to what else she
said
then she said
they look at the labor market consumer
and business spending industrial
production incomes based on these data
it's unlikely the decline in gdp in the
first quarter this year even if followed
by another gdp decline in the second
quarter indicates a recession that's the
end of the uh
first paragraph of the blog post and
then of course yellen following up with
same talking points and most of the data
that they look at right now continues to
be strong i'd be amazed that they would
declare this period to be a recession
even it happens to have two quarters of
negative growth we have very strong
labor market when you are creating
almost 400 000 jobs a month that is not
a recession now
let's say that these people have good
intentions give them better for the
doubt
and if they have good intentions what
they're trying to say
is
gdp growth
is likely to be negative in q1 and q2
but we have a strong labor market with
strong employment and consumer spending
is still very healthy that's fine but
say that
don't tell us and gaslight us that a
recession is not two consecutive
quarters of gdp growth
that is exactly what a recession is
instead simply say look shit's hard
we're doing the best we can it's a
complex system no one can predict the
future and therefore we are going to
enter recession because the fed is
destroying demand
so naturally gdp growth is going to go
negative when that happens we are
technically in a recession but this is
not like the 2008 2009 global financial
crisis instead we still have strong
employment we still have great consumer
spending and this is a very unique type
of recession
it's a stagflationary period and
therefore
while you may hear the word recession
used because it meets technical
definition do not be alarmed in the same
way that you were alarmed in 2008 2009
they would have way more credibility
with people if they just simply stated
that rather than
gaslight everyone and say that a
recession is not going to happen like
we're already in the recession and
literally they're out here saying like i
don't see a recession coming
come on